[Musique]
lever de drapeau pour le 20e
anniversaire du pghm
tous les acteurs du secours en montagne
sont présents tout comme l'hélicoptère
bleus qui passent chaque jour au dessus
de nos têtes
depuis 20 ans dix mille personnes ont
été secourues par ces hommes qui font
visiter ce jour là leur lieu de travail
à la ministre d outre-mer avec la mairie
vers soir du pghm mais c'est aussi et
surtout une façon de mettre en lumière
et tout tout tout tout tout les gens qui
nous aident sur cette base
toutes ces personnes qui sont tout le
temps tous les jours avec nous la
réunion est un terrain de jeu mais
jarre dire que c'est une terre
magnifique et qui nécessitent en fait
que je sois là aussi chaque jour tous
les acteurs du secours en montagne sont
mobilisés raison pour laquelle il était
essentiel que le département soit
présent quand il s'agit de porter
secours à des personnes en danger l'état
comme les services de l'état bien
souvent bien l'essentiel de nos
montagnes se situe sur la partie des
portes montrent de manière que nous
entretenons avec les services de la nef
et lorsque les services de gendarmerie
interviennent sur ce domaine est bien
pour nous nous devons être attentifs à
leur offrait les meilleures conditions
de travail
l'année dernière les 17 gendarmes ont
été appelés plus de 800 fois sur le
terrain un engagement que la ministre a
voulu saluer on a cité aujourd'hui tous
ceux qui participent avec eux à la
solidarité à l'intervention en montagne
pour quelqu'un intervient derrière lui
il ya beaucoup d'autres
un homme qui se sentent engagés ça c'est
important
cet anniversaire illustre le savoir
faire réunionnais dans ce domaine celui
d'un travail collectif pour le bien de
la population
[Musique]